- [Voiceover] Hey Paige!
- [Voiceover] What's up David?
- [Voiceover] Is this right?
Okay, so I'm about to
go to the grocery store,
and it looks like it says,
"I need to get squid pickles
and chocolate at the grocery store."
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- [Voiceover] Did you want squid pickles?
- [Voiceover] No, I
wanted squid and pickles.
- [Voiceover] I must have
written it down wrong, okay.
So I think what we need to
do in order to fix this list
and avoid confusion like this
in the future is using
commas to punctuate a list.
'Cause right now this just
looks like squid pickles,
which, I mean probably
delicious, pickled squid.
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- [Voiceover] Probably delicious.
- [Voiceover] Sure.
- [Voiceover] But not what
we were looking to get today.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] If we don't want
to get pickled squid today,
then we have to put commas
in between the elements of the list.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] Right, because
this is what commas do.
The separate elements of every everything.
So let's put in those dividers.
I need to get squid,
comma, pickles, comma,
and chocolate at the grocery store.
- [Voiceover] Exactly.
- [Voiceover] Okay, so
we can punctuate a list
by separating out nouns, and
I see from the second sentence
here, Paige could you
give me a read for that?
- [Voiceover] I'm going to
go for a run, read a chapter
of my book and go see the
new Colonel Justice movie.
- [Voiceover] Oh I hear that's good.
So right now it says that,
but it could also just
be "I'm going to go for
a run read a chapter
of my book, and go see..."
you know there's like no--
- [Voiceover] It's a little confusing.
- [Voiceover] It's a
little confusing, right?
There could be such a thing as a run read.
- [Voiceover] There probably is.
- [Voiceover] You know, like where you go
for a jog while holding a book.
- [Voiceover] Sounds difficult.
- [Voiceover] And so we can
also use commas in lists
to separate not just nouns
like in this first one,
but also verb phrases.
So I'm going for a run, comma,
read a chapter of my book,
comma, and go see the new
Colonel Justice movie.
- [Voiceover] Perfect.
- [Voiceover] Cool.
So that's how you punctuate
a list with commas.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, you got it.
- [Voiceover] You can learn anything.
David out.
- [Voiceover] Paige out.